Traduttore: Claude Almansi
Revisore: Maria Pia Lanfranchi
(Applauso)
Qual è l'origine della felicità?
Alcuni ricercatori se lo sono chiesto
e hanno scoperto che la cosa fondamentale
è avere delle buone relazioni sociali,
una salute fisica ed emotiva.
E la scuola ha un ruolo molto importante
nel crescere un adulto soddisfatto.
Voi lo immaginavate?
Io no, pensavo che fosse la famiglia
la cosa più importante.
E, invece, le cose stanno cambiando.
Voglio raccontarvi
la storia di mio nipote
che si chiama Mattia.
A tre anni, lui cercava
sullo smartphone di suo papà,
i video che voleva vedere
e anche i giochini.
Usava la ricerca vocale, perché
la sorella si era stufata di aiutarlo.
Qualche mese fa è andato a scuola,
ha iniziato la prima elementare
e ha fatto un viaggio nel tempo
perché si è trovato nell'aula
esattamente uguale
a quella dei suoi genitori.
Si è seduto, e la mattinata
è trascorsa abbastanza bene,
fino a quando l'insegnante ha detto:
"Bene, bambini, ci vediamo domani."
A quel punto, Mattia ha esclamato:
"Fermi tutti, perché domani
devo tornare qui?"
Ai bambini diciamo
che devono mangiare i broccoli,
perché gli fanno bene.
Allo stesso modo, gli diciamo
che devono stare seduti,
ascoltare quello che gli viene detto,
perché un giorno gli sarà utile.
Eppure, il dibattito internazionale
ci dice cose diverse.
Ci parla di apprendimento connesso,
ci dice che bisogna
partire dalle passioni,
che bisogna farli lavorare fra di loro
e basarsi su problemi concreti.
Il gioco fa un po' questo.
Si parte da problemi complessi
che non sappiamo come risolvere.
E poi, si possono, in questo senso...
Si può usare l'approccio
dei videogiochi a scuola.
Per esempio, cambiando
il modo di fare lezione,
organizzando delle missioni,
che possono essere, a loro volta,
suddivise in piccole attività di ricerca.
Oppure, più semplicemente, cominciare
con un'approccio più semplice,
usando, per esempio, dei quiz temporizzati
per gammificare la lezione.
Perché è scientificamente dimostrato
che rispondere in gara con altri
produce un apprendimento migliore
perché il gioco ci dà un incentivo
a raggiungere l'obiettivo.
Lo sappiamo, per esperienza,
che, per giocare, bisogna
impegnarsi molto,
ma è quello che ci dà soddisfazione
la fatica, lo sforzo,
l'impegno e la concentrazione.
Per questo non sto dicendo che la scuola
debba diventare un luna park.
Giocare significa mettere
in atto delle strategie,
procedere per errori e tentativi,
ma non vuol dire
che sbagliare sia un problema.
Si cresce attraverso gli errori,
si procede al proprio ritmo
e si vedono i risultati
del proprio miglioramento.
Alessandra è una bambina di dodici anni,
anche lei è mia nipote,
e fa la seconda media.
E a cinque anni usava già
il computer del papà
però è andata alle elementari
e queste competenze
non le sono servite a nulla
perché per 5 anni non hanno mai visto
un computer a scuola.
Adesso fa la seconda media
e in classe c'è una LIM,
una lavagna interattiva.
Però i professori non sono molto abituati
ad usarla
e poi hanno anche dei problemi tecnici
perché la connessione in rete
non sempre funziona bene.
Quest'anno però
la professoressa gli ha detto
che useranno i videogiochi in classe,
ma non quelli che ha sul telefonino
il videogioco dovrano progettarselo loro.
La maestra è entrata in un programma
che si chiama "Programmo anch'io".
che aiuta, appunto, le classi
ad avvicinarsi a questo tipo di linguaggio
"Programmo anch'io"
è un'iniziativa di Dschola,
una comunità di insegnanti
che ho contribuito a crescere
un po' di anni fa.
Lo slogan è "Le scuole per le scuole"
perché crediamo nella
condivisione della conoscenza
E lo facciamo, appunto,
proponendo questi strumenti
come il linguaggio Scratch
che è stato inventato al MIT
per favorire la creatività.
E anche organizziamo un festival nazionale
per videogiochi sviluppati a scuola.
Marcello Bozzi è uno di questi professori
di questa comunità,
insegna qui a Grugliasco,
all'Istituto Majorana
e crede che i videogiochi
siano il linguaggio
che ci permette di metterci
nei panni dei nostri ragazzi.
Lui voleva affrontare in classe
il problema dei migranti siriani
che vengono in Europa
per trovare un futuro migliore.
Un argomento un po' difficile
che poteva risultare un po'...
magari affrontato superficialmente.
E così ha pensato di far progettare
ai suoi allievi un videogioco
il videogioco si chiama "Il viaggio"
ed è un gioco a squadre
in cui ogni squadra è una famiglia
in cui deve decidere
se portarsi dietro una foto
o un paio di scarpe.
Immaginate come, appunto,
questo possa avere aumentato
il coinvolgimento dei ragazzi
li abbia aiutati davvero
- e, questa volta, loro -
a mettersi nei panni di qualcun altro
e a sviluppare un pensiero critico
e una maggiore consapevolezza.
L'ultima storia che vi voglio raccontare
è quella di Lorenzo.
Questo non è mio nipote.
Frequenta la quarta superiore
e sta facendo un corso per imparare Unity
Unity è uno dei linguaggi professionali
per sviluppare videogiochi
Lui vorrebbe lavorare in quel settore.
Quindi quando il suo insegnante
gli ha detto che quest'anno
avrebbe partecipato a una game jam
nell'arco dell'alternanza scuola-lavoro
non si è lasciato scappare l'opportunità.
Le game jam sono delle maratone
di sviluppo di videogiochi
in cui sviluppatori, game designer,
sound designer, artisti
ma anche non professionisti, studenti,
si ritrovano in un weekend
e sviluppano un prototipo di gioco
su un tema dato.
Lo fanno per passione, perché gli piace.
Le game jam permettono appunto
di sviluppare alcune abilità
come lavorare insieme
con persone che non si conoscono
con una pressione legata al fatto
che devono produrre un risultato
in un tempo breve
con delle risorse limitate.
Devono ridefinire il problema,
fare brainstorming
ed è uno sforzo anche impegnativo
sul piano fisico
perché devono lavorare ininterrottamente
per due giorni e due notti.
Però lo fanno tutti nello stesso spazio
e questo crea un senso
di comunità e di condivisione.
Per questo penso
che un approccio di questo tipo
possa essere utile anche a scuola
perché non sappiamo ancora
come sarà la scuola del XXI secolo.
Forse non ci saranno più i voti,
forse cambieranno le scansioni
dei tempi e degli spazi,
forse ci saranno delle materie diverse,
ci saranno delle materie in meno
perché forse studiamo troppe cose.
Ci saranno dei corsi più astratti.
Un esempio, per esempio,
è quello di fare delle sfide
dare a dei ragazzi dei progetti
che possono sviluppare in modo autonomo
con un piccolo budget
perché magari vogliono fare
delle esperienze.
Il lavoro di domani
non sappiamo come sarà:
forse sarà meno ripetitivo,
sarà meno faticoso.
Però serviranno abilità diverse,
servirà empatia,
capacità di comunicare con persone
con una cultura diversa dalla nostra;
saper collaborare, analizzare problemi
e prendere decisioni
i videogiochi forse
in questo possono aiutarci
ed è compito degli insegnanti
svelare ai ragazzi
che attraverso questi sistemi possono
sviluppare queste competenze.
Perché l'importante è che la scuola deve
dare motivazione e ottimismo ai ragazzi,
perché credano nelle loro capacità
e non abbiano paura di affrontare
un futuro troppo difficile per loro.
Ma ancora più importante
è che lo facciano per tutti
perché come abbiamo visto,
la scuola è fondamentale
per il benessere degli adulti.
Ed è per questo che Matteo
domani tornerà a scuola.
Grazie.
(applauso)